Now we've been working a lot with rectangles and you may wonder whether there
are shapes you can use, and indeed you can. I'm going to show you know more
about the graphics library that you get with this course. It's a simple
library, I've created it especially for this course. It's very similar to the
standard Java library but it's a bit easier to use. You can find the full
documentation on the web. But let's just walk through the basics so you get a
feel for what you can do. Here is an example of a silly drawing that you can
create. When you look at the drawing, you can see rectangles, lines, circles,
and text. You already know about rectangles, so let's move on to the other
elements. Let's say you want to draw a line from this point to this one. You
need the coordinates of the start and the end. And then you simply construct
the line by giving the coordinates to the line constructor. You store the
object in a variable. And when you're ready to draw it you call the draw
method, just like you would for rectangles. Now let's say if you want to draw a
circle or an ellipse. A circle is just an ellipse that's symmetrical. Find the
rectangle that fits around the ellipse. Determine its top left corner, its
width, and its height. And then construct the ellipse, really in the same way,
as you would have constructed, the surrounding rectangle. Finally if you want
to show some text, specify the top left corner point, and construct a text
object. Simply give the coordinates and the message that you want to display.
That, in a nutshell, is our graphics library. Sara has prepared a couple of
simple practice problems for you.